il a l'air normal pourtant quand est-ce
que ça a commencé quand hélène est parti
travailler je suppose qu'elle est aux
courts non mais tu plaisantes comment
veux tu parles de ça c'est sa toute
première mission
je dois réussir afin qu'elle puisse
réussir afin que nous puissions réussir
ibor gecko prix du bois de cantat pas
dormi j'en sais rien j'ai pas noté et
puis c'est un bébé je suis capable de
gérer sage gerges j'ai donc tout va très
bien
tu contrôle parfaitement la situation au
bouquet tac chaque fois dit damien hamou
qui inquiète m
si j'ai bien compris il est capable de
tan tan m dans l'autre dimension lui il
est trop bizarre
pour
tu t'es laver les mains avec du savon
tu les a bien séché je vous le demande
notamment des légumes c'est moi sinon
est ce qu il est prévu qu'on en parle un
jour quoi du sujet tabou évidemment
quels sujets tabous nouveau travail de
maman
il est temps grand temps de réparer nos
erreurs
aidez nous à faire sortir de l'ombre
tous les supers nous devons changer
l'opinion des gens sur les super-héros
et pour cela élastique girl est notre
meilleur atout meilleur que moi je
m'occupe les enfants pas quand même
c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut faire papa
le prof dit qu'on doit utiliser cette
méthode je connais pas cette méthode est
pourquoi ils changent les matchs très
bien j'ai peur c'est ça la petite de
l'instance et jack jack est très en
forme c'est quoi ça ok d'accord ça c'est
plus beau c'est complètement fou pour
aider ma famille je dois l'aquitaine
pour faire régner la loi la transgresser
pour nos enfants pour qu'ils puissent
avoir le choix
[Musique]
combustion imminent qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire y'a le feu
aubin
les lotissements theron ce programme
afin de vous délivrer un message enfile
son costume ça va chauffer j'arrive tu
me dépêche
[Musique]